braucht nicht ich glaube wir müssen
jetzt mal langsam beginnen nicht mehr
für alles geld auszugeben
jetzt geht uns das geld nicht aus ich
glaube dass auch das gefühl der
allermeisten menschen sich eher sorgen
aber ich frage machen kann der staat das
eigentlich alles wir werden aufpassen
müssen dass wir geld für die dinge haben
die wirklich absolut zwingend nötig sind
und bei anderen dingen muss einfach
aufpassen das nützt nichts jetzt solche
versprechen in die welt zu setzen
wir haben am ende andere aufgaben und
ich gebe wolfgang bosbach recht wenn man
den gastronomen drücke jesus helfen will
dann senkt den mehrwertsteuer dauerhaft
davon haben die mehr als mit solchen
coups urlaubsgutschein bisschen anders
helikopter geld von donald trump
erinnern